esta vez vamos a trabajar con el famoso
o tal vez infame problema de la papa del
examen up el cálculo del 2017 y dice así
en el tiempo de igual a cero una papa
cocida se retira de la olla de la estufa
y se deja enfriar en la cocina la
temperatura interna de la papa es de 91
grados celsius en el tiempo de igual a
cero ok esto es importante 91 grados
celsius en el tiempo te iguala 0 y la
temperatura interna de la papa es
siempre mayor que 27 grados celsius para
todo el tiempo te mayor que 0 este medio
es importante es siempre mayor que 27
grados celsius para todo tiempo t mayor
que 0 con esto podemos suponer que la
temperatura ambiente del cuarto es de 27
grados celsius y es por eso que la
temperatura de la papa se va a aproximar
a esa temperatura pero siempre se va a
mantener a una temperatura un poco más
alta mientras te crece y crece y crece
la temperatura interna de la papa en el
tiempo t minutos puede ser modelada por
h que satisface la ecuación diferencial
la derivada de h con respecto a tema es
igual a menos un cuarto que multiplica a
h
27 donde hd tm se mide en grados celsius
ok y 70 es igual a 91 bien aquí tengo mi
ecuación diferencial y tengo que htc
hero es igual a 91 ok antes de leer el
inciso am vamos a entender que nos está
diciendo
esta ecuación diferencial y veamos si
ésta es consistente con nuestra
intuición para eso déjame dibujar por
aquí unos ejes los voy a poner por aquí
aquí tengo a mi gente y por acá tengo a
mí es igual a http y bueno voy a suponer
que por aquí tengo la temperatura
ambiente que como ya sabemos es de 27
grados celsius así que déjenme anotarlo
este de aquí es 27 grados celsius grados
celsius ok y por acá tengo que mi papá
en el tiempo te iguala 0 tienen una
temperatura
de 91 grados celsius ok y lo que
esperamos de manera intuitiva es que la
papa empiece a enfriarse y cuando hay
una gran diferencia entre la temperatura
de la papa y del cuarto la tasa de
cambio estará más empinada
es decir vamos a tener una tasa de
cambio más empinada cuando tengamos una
gran diferencia de temperatura y entre
más nos acerquemos a la temperatura del
ambiente la temperatura de la papa va a
tener una tasa de cambio menos inclinada
y se va a ver algo más o menos así
tenemos como assín total a la
temperatura del ambiente de 27 grados
celsius de lujo y esta ecuación
diferencial que tengo aquí es
consistente con eso observa que la tasa
de cambio para todas t mayor que 0 nos
da un valor negativo como nuestra
temperatura es mayor que 27 entonces
esta diferencia va a ser algo positivo y
cuando lo multiplicamos por un número
negativo me va a dar una tasa de cambio
negativa lo cual tiene muchos
porque la papa se está enfriando y
también tiene sentido que la tasa de
cambio sea proporcional a la diferencia
entre la temperatura interna de la papa
y la temperatura ambiente cuando existe
una gran diferencia esperamos que la
tasa de cambio sea más empinada y cuando
hay una diferencia muy pequeña esperamos
que la tasa de cambio que puedas ver sea
menos y menos y menos empinada de manera
que se aproxime a la cim total de la
temperatura del ambiente bien ahora con
este principio es momento de leer el
primer inciso escribe una ecuación para
la recta tangente a la gráfica h entre
igual a cero usa esa ecuación para
aproximar la temperatura interna de la
papa en el tiempo t igual a 3 así que
qué vamos a hacer vamos a pensar qué es
lo que ocurre entre igual a 0 es decir
vamos a ver qué es lo que está pasando
justo aquí y lo que vamos a hacer es
fijarnos en la recta tangente a s
que se va a ver más o menos así va a ser
una recta que se vea más o menos así
esta va a ser mi recta tangente en el
tiempo de igual a cero y como sabemos
que es una recta entonces podemos decir
que su ecuación va a ser de la forma
bien igual a la pendiente de mi recta
tangente que ya sabemos que es la
derivada de h con respecto al tiempo la
derivada de h con respecto al tiempo
esto evaluado en el tiempo e igual a 0
que va a multiplicar ate ya esto hay que
sumarle bueno la intersección con el eje
i
pero si observas ínter secamos al eje y
james en el valor de 91 de 91 grados
celsius entonces a esto le voy a sumar
91 y ahora cuando te es igual a cero
quiero saber cuánto vale esta derivada
es decir a esto de aquí
lo podemos ver también como h prima de t
y por lo tanto si busco h
prima de 0 esto me va a quedar igual a
menos un cuarto ok que va a multiplicar
a h de 0 a nuestra temperatura inicial
-27 ok pero sabemos cuánto vale nuestra
temperatura inicial nos lo dicen es este
punto de aquí y por lo tanto esto vale
91 y ahora sí me queda 91 menos 27
eso es 64 64 entre 4 es lo mismo que en
16 y por este signo menos me quedan
menos 16 ok entonces ya sé que la
derivada de h con respecto al tiempo en
el tiempo está igual a 0 es menos 16 así
que en lugar de esto voy a poner menos
16 y ya con esto tengo la ecuación para
la recta tangente a la gráfica h en el
tiempo e igual a cero es más déjame
escribirla de nuevo un pequeño redoble
de tambor porque esta va a ser bien
igual a menos 16
ok más 91 de lujo después me dicen usan
esa ecuación para aproximar la
temperatura interna de la papa en el
tiempo tema igual a 3 así que si por
aquí tengo el tiempo de igual a 3
entonces mi función toman el valor que
tengo aquí sin embargo queremos
aproximar la temperatura que describe
este modelo con la ecuación de la recta
tangente ente igual a 3 es decir evaluar
la justo aquí y por lo tanto vamos a
evaluar esta recta entre igual a 3 así
que vamos a obtener menos 16 que
multiplica a 3 ok esto más 91 y cuánto
es esto viene 3 por 10 y 648 y este
signo menos me queda menos 48 ok y ahora
tengo menos 48 más 91
eso es lo mismo que
43 43 grados celsius por lo tanto esta
de aquí es mi ecuación para mi recta
tangente en el tiempo de igual a 0 y por
acá tenemos la aproximación usando esta
recta tangente para la temperatura
interna de mi papá en el tiempo de igual
a 3 en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
continuar con el inciso b